the U.S is headed for another debt
ceiling fight the Democrats as usual are
using the threat of making the nation
default on the debt as an excuse to Ram
through a bunch of payoffs for their
cronies Kevin McCarthy the Republican
leader in the house is insisting on a
Slimmer Bill to avoid defaulting on debt
without spending lots of money on
liberal nonsense what is the White House
position on the matter
the White House is arguing that if
Republicans don't cave on every
ludicrous spending item the Democrats
are proposing
our bones the bones in our bodies will
literally melt the president's bold
climate and environmental justice agenda
could not stand in Starker contrast to
the dangerous proposals Maga House
Republicans are putting forward as you
can see from the slide behind me
here you go while President Biden is
fighting to clean up toxic pollution and
lower costs through clean energy tax
credit
speaker McCarthy unveiled a ransom note
holding our economy hostage it's a 320
page plan to kill jobs fill our cities
with Smog and give asthma to our
children
The Proposal would repeal the inflation
reduction acts green energy tax credits
sending thousands of jobs back to China
it would make it easier for oil
companies to use toxic chemicals that
cause severe burns damage people's eyes
and quite literally melt bones
that's one of the craziest things I've
ever heard from a White House Press
Secretary not just from this one who is
particularly hyperbolic but from any of
them but the wildest part of that
statement is that putting the debt
ceiling aside for a second
the White House has uniquely among all
presidential administrations
embraced a policy that would destroy
bones inasmuch as this Administration
uniquely has embraced transgender
surgeries including for children one of
the main side effects of which is
osteoporosis the weakening of bone
density such that many victims of these
quack procedures are permanently
crippled by them
it's not just that the White House line
is dishonest it's that it's completely
backwards
but this is the sort of thing that we've
come to expect especially from this
White House Press Secretary last month
when this White House Press Secretary
baselessly accused me of supporting
genocide the greatest irony of that lie
was that the White House itself supports
genocide through abortion which
Slaughters some 800 000 babies each year
not only are we not doing the thing
they're accusing us of they themselves
uniquely are guilty of it
it's not a new phenomenon but it's worth
pointing out every time that they prove
it when the libs make an accusation not
only should you assume it isn't true you
should assume that they themselves are
guilty of it I'm Michael knowlesis the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode I
am so pleased to tell you is brought to
you by good ranchers free bacon great
meat a secure price and an extra twenty
dollars off with my code Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s head on over to
goodranchers.com use my code Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s for twenty dollars off
your order
some really spicy footage from the
liberal establishment on the January 6th
worst day ever in all of history debacle
and one of the men who's at the heart of
that debacle Ray Epps we'll get to that
in just a little second first though I
want to focus a little bit on
the green New Deal and the White House
spending and what the Democrats are up
to here we we have this debt ceiling
fight regularly and we could have a
relatively clean bill to raise the debt
ceiling to give the Republicans a little
bit of what they want which is to rein
in some of the spending raise the debt
ceiling okay we move on we're not
addressing any of our underlying
economic problems but here's where we
are and the Democrats won't do that the
Democrats are using this as an
opportunity to Ram through all sorts of
insane spending
AOC
has just upped the ante even further by
reintroducing the green New Deal
remember the green New Deal when she
first introduced it some years ago it it
would have cost something like 90
trillion dollars over 10 years would
have completely upended not just our
Environmental Policy but our whole
economy it would have gone down to every
level of our society it would have
forced people to knock down their
buildings and rebuild new green energy
efficient buildings it would have it
would have impacted every aspect of our
political economy
and people laughed at her at the time
remember Mitch McConnell said well I
really hope that the Democrats vote on
this we need to bring this up to the
floor for a vote immediately and
everyone is giggling hahaha AOC is going
to embarrass the Democrats this is going
to go nowhere it's going to hurt the
Democrats in the elections
well Who's Laughing Now aoc's
reintroducing the spending plan
Senator Ed Markey is introducing it in
the Senate and here's what AOC said she
said when we first introduced the green
new deal we were told that our vision
for the future was too aspirational four
years later we see core tenants of the
green New Deal reflected in the
inflation reduction act the largest ever
Federal investment in fighting climate
change with a focus on creating good
green jobs put a pause right there even
the Democrats are admitting the
inflation reduction act had nothing to
do with inflation it actually made
inflation worse the inflation reduction
Act was entirely about climate change
climate change being the animating
propaganda for their entire radical
agenda and they admitted this not just
now they admitted it right after the
inflation reduction act packs even
Bernie Sanders said this was not a bill
about inflation this is a completely
different Bill and he did it seems want
to bring down inflation which was
hurting Americans but no they just
rammed it through as a climate change
bill and the inflation reduction act
included parts of the green New Deal
well now AOC wants the rest of it she
goes on she says
there is still much much more to do
today's reintroduction marks the
beginning of that process of
strengthening and broadening our
Coalition and of laying the policy
groundwork for the next fight this is a
really important lesson for the American
right
we on the American right were too timid
we suffer from a failure of imagination
we think that if we tell people clearly
what we want and what we think that oh
it's going to scare off the moderate
voters
the Centrist of the voters the Suburban
women in the suburbs of some part of the
country
we can't do it
did the Democrats worry about that
do the Democrats ever worry about
turning off the moderate voters no
the Democrats
just in the last 10 years
redefined marriage the fundamental
political building block they have
pushed now for a sacramental view of
abortion that permits abortion at any
moment up until the very second before
birth they rammed this through in New
York and elsewhere around the country
they've pushed not only to chop off
people's genitals but to chop off the
genitals of very young people to put
little kids on cross-sex hormones to
introduce transgender ideology into
kindergarten and preschool to to put
drag queens in elementary schools and
libraries to read to little kids
and on and on and on and on to pass a 90
trillion dollar bill to upend our entire
social order
they don't worry about it and does it
cost them anything sometimes in the
short term yeah maybe but in the long
term they know that they win in the long
term on an issue like this AOC is going
to have the last laugh
because the the conservatives ironically
see the conclusion of these policies
we understand what the slippery slope
looks like we know that if you redefine
the relationship between men and women
back in the 1970s we know that that's
going to lead to redefining marriage and
redefining even human nature itself we
know that we predict that
at least the so the social conservatives
do the traditional conservatives do
but then we have a failure of
imagination where we say but that's
that's probably that couldn't happen
they're not really going to do that
right there's no way
the most shocking aspect of the whole
transgender debate which nobody can shut
up about the most shocking aspect of it
to me
is that we're talking about it
did you ever think in the year 2023 that
we would be discussing at what age it's
appropriate to chop off somebody's
genitals
the Liberals imagined that and then they
did it and maybe conservatives when we
have a clear vision of society maybe we
just need to push and push and push and
don't give up and don't allow one little
election cycle to get us down
and don't allow the headlines from CNN
to get us down and just keep pushing
like AOC good honor you know what she's
doing is awful it's a terrible idea but
good honor she's got political vision
and she's got political Talent and right
now she is having the latest laugh on
this issue no doubt about it
speaking of our sexual Revolution
headline in New York Post
gay thruppel hopes to be second in U.S
to officially be parents so these are
three guys who like each other more than
guys who are supposed to like each other
in a different way than guys are
supposed to like each other and they're
pretending that they're married and now
they're adopting a child when things get
really crazy in your economy you're
going to want to have your wealth and
some tangible assets you're going to
want to consider Birch gold right now
text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 the
government spending is out of control
long-term bonds have diminished in value
it's crippling Banks
depositors are holding their breath
investors are bailing on Bank stocks you
can't spend your way out of inflation
right now text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98
and this volatile Market diversification
has never been more important that's why
buying gold with Birch gold is such a
smart choice gold is a tangible asset
with a reliable store of value because
it's not tied to any one economy or
currency it can be a safe haven in times
of Crisis gold can help you hedge
against inflation because its value
tends to rise when the cost of living
increases unlike other assets such as
paper currency the supply of gold is
limited
which can help to maintain its value
over time Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into a
tax sheltered Ira in physical precious
metals such as gold and silver
time to start thinking about your
Investments and your future you need to
consider diversifying into gold with
Birch gold today text Knowles kwles to
98 98 98 to claim your free info kit on
gold and talk to a precious metals
expert text Knowles to 98 98 98 the New
York Post is known for some pretty crazy
headlines
craziest part of this headline though
it's not the gay throuple part it's not
the idea that they're adopting it's the
they're not even the first to do it this
has already happened once before now
there's another Trio of men who
want to adopt a little child
from the article quote
Tegan is going to love having three dads
she will always have so much love
we would let them know Love Is Love from
a mother or a father and them here one
of these men is referring to them in the
singular
so saying the daughter instead of saying
let her know saying let them know that
Love Is Love from a mother or a father
Ben said one of the fathers according to
the independent
so that sounds really nice that's a nice
happy liberal line look she's gonna have
so much love we're going to let her know
that Love Is Love from a mother or a
father but what's the translation of
that the translation of that sentence is
mothers aren't important
mothers don't matter at all
baby doesn't need a mother forget about
a baby doesn't need a mother sometimes
tragedies happen mothers die okay
mothers don't matter
mothers don't add anything to raising a
child that's what that means
and that is the view that is now popular
in Liberal circles and it's the view
reflected in our law
the moment that any
municipality in this country
permitted
gay adoption
I'll go further back the moment that any
municipality in this country permitted
single mother adoption
or single a single father adoption a
thing I hope not but probably it is
these days
the moment that the moment that our law
said that marriage is either the union
of a man and a woman or the union of two
men or the union of two women the moment
that the law said those things
the law said mothers don't matter or
conversely fathers don't matter
that's fine you know there's no there's
no advantage to having a mother or a
father
it's just whatever whatever adults want
to do to satisfy their sexual appetites
and Fantasies that's all that matters
and then if they want a kid because they
have a natural longing to have a kid
well that's fine and if they're in a
disordered sort of situation well you
know
they're just that's just love is love
is love wouldn't it be good if the kid
had a mother though don't you think not
lunch Love Is Love
is love that's what that means The Story
Goes On
from one of the fellas
to know that I'm making a path for other
relationships that look like mine feels
good it reminds me of the early days
when I was fighting for legal rights to
get married to a man or two lesbians to
marry
this is a really important sentence
because he's wrong about the idea that
two men can marry each other or the two
women can marry each other that's not
possible there's no no
hate on the fellas you know I got plenty
of friends who have all sorts of
Divergent views of sex and gender okay
I'm from New York I went to a very gay
University I lived in La I have a
disproportionate number of friends who
are have gone down these paths and have
these kinds of views okay and there's no
animus toward anybody at all it's simply
a fact of the meaning of the word
marriage that if marriage is to have any
meaning at all it has to involve sexual
difference
the moment you take that away you take
all the boundaries off of marriage and
very quickly thereafter you end up with
a throuple all the conservatives who
said well if we're going to redefine
marriage to take away sexual difference
why won't we have polygamy soon
and what did the lib say they said
that's a crazy ridiculous slippery slope
stupid argument well here we are it's
not
marriage wasn't redefined all that long
ago and now we've got not the not the
first thrupple to adopt children but the
second
and you're going to see the third and
the fourth and the fifth
and the sixth the point that he makes
here though is actually a very good
point one of these fellas he says this
reminds me of the early days when I was
fighting for legal rights to redefine
all these things and I know that I'm
making a path for other relationships
that look like mine that's true
if we tolerate this as a matter of
culture and law we're gonna get more of
it
one of the big mistakes that the right
has made in recent decades is we've
bought into some kind of magical
thinking
According to which if the government
Outlaws something you don't necessarily
get less of it
and if the government encourages
something you don't necessarily get more
of it you see this especially in Shallow
debates over drugs every every pot head
sophomore in college will say hey man
you know what I I think we should
legalize all the drugs because the thing
is man if you legalize the drugs you're
going to get less of the drugs now man
because it's illegal everyone's doing it
more but if you make it legal man you
probably get a lot less of it you know
what I mean man
that's what they say and that has never
been true anywhere ever in human history
and it's just a basic fact of economics
and human life if you incentivize
something you get more of it if you
disincentivize something you get less of
it and right now our society
has laid all of the groundwork to
incentivize
thruples
and thruples adopting poor little kids
who will be intentionally deprived of a
mother or of a father
and that's wrong that's very wrong and
if we're gonna if we all know that this
is wrong as we all do
then we have to ask well why is it wrong
and if we want to correct that wrong
we're going to have to go back and fix
some of the errors that we've made in
recent years speaking of Fallout from
this weird
sexual Revolution
is an athlete North Carolina female
athlete who has sustained massive
injuries after being spiked in the face
with a volleyball by a trans woman
athlete so a man who identifies as a
woman spiking this ball into her face
there's a video of
[Music]
all goes up okay here comes
this ladylike trans
you don't want to look at it because you
know it's it's so clear it's so awful
knocks this poor actual woman down
and gives her all sorts of injuries the
woman was just speaking in North
Carolina on what those injuries have
been like
I was severely injured in a high school
volleyball game by a transgender Athlete
on the opposing team
I suffered from a concussion and neck
injury that to this day I'm still
recovering from
other injuries I still suffer from today
include impaired Vision partial
Paralysis on my right side constant
headaches as well as anxiety and
depression
I was unable to play the rest of my last
volleyball season and although I'm
currently playing softball I'm not able
to perform as well as I know I have in
the past because of the injury
my ability to learn retain comprehend
has also been impaired and I require
accommodations at school for testing
because of this allowing biological
males to compete against biological
females is dangerous
I may be the first to come before you
with an injury if this doesn't pass I
won't be the last
certainly she won't be the last as we
see more and more of this as we see
transgenderism as a social contagion
don't forget the rates of transgender
identification among youth have
skyrocketed in recent years
going up fifty percent a hundred percent
over historic rates
you're going to see more of this and
you're going to see more of this on the
volleyball court and in all of the
sports leagues and I've said before
talking about the Integrity of women's
sports is a is a perfectly fine example
to highlight the absurdity of the
transgender ideology
but
it's not the main reason why
transgenderism is wrong as I've pointed
out nobody watches the WNBA nobody
really cares about women's sports per se
we care about women's sports because
it's an example of the Injustice of this
transgender ideology the argument for
transgenderism is these poor confused
people they're having a rough go of it
so let's just let the fellas go into the
women's bathroom and let's let the
fellas play in the women's team and
let's just kind of go along with it okay
well here's the cost of that this is a
finite world everything has costs
everything has trade-offs we're just
talking about economics so the question
you've got to ask yourself is is it
worth it
is it worth concussing young women and
partially paralyzing them
and and permanently disabling them
to affirm the fantasies of men
there are going to be people out there
who say yeah that's worth it
something tells me it's going to be the
same people who say babies don't need
mothers yeah mothers don't add anything
women don't add anything to society we
don't we don't need to recognize sexual
difference who care I bet it's going to
be the same people who say all of those
things but but that's not what I would
say
I would say it most certainly is not
worth concussing young women young girls
to indulge
especially when it's on the premise that
by indulging this we're gonna vastly
improve the mental health outcomes of
these young
people when we don't there's no evidence
that that happens at all and in fact the
largest data set on the transgender
phenomenon has shown and there's an
excellent article about this over at
Heritage by Ryan T Anderson that largest
data set
has shown that there is no mental health
Improvement as a result of the
transgender procedures both Surgical and
hormonal and in fact on one score on the
score of anxiety it would seem that the
people who have these procedures do
worse okay so nobody benefits
everybody is harmed and some people are
harmed especially we're talking
especially about a woman like this poor
young gal who now has permanent injuries
okay now
I do have some good news amidst all this
crazy culture the good news is you can
get great meat at a great price if you
check out good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code Knowles
if you've not changed the way that you
buy meat yet you really need to I'm
going to give you three reasons that I
personally subscribe to good ranchers
number one good ranchers is giving you
free bacon for a year that's a pound and
a half of bacon in every box that's a
240 value second good ranchers offers a
price lock guarantee which is insane
when we've got record inflation means
that when you subscribe
your price does not change for the
entire length of your subscription when
the price of meat is expected to
increase by another four and a half
percent in the coming year this could be
a huge savings for you and your family
third golden ranchers meet is unlike any
other they're all natural Burgers USDA
prime steaks and better than organic
chicken will change your standard for
great meat I am very particular when it
comes to my food okay I am easily
Satisfied by the very best good ranchers
is Far and Away the best out there the
quality of the meat is just insane and I
eat good ranchers if not for the
outright majority of my meals total
three meals a day at least for the
plurality of them okay I just adore good
ranchers goodranchers.com use code
knowleskin wles for twenty dollars off
your box free bacon great meat a secure
price and a bonus 20 bucks off today
promo code Knowles at goodranchers.com
goodranchors.com American Meat delivered
you know when leftists tell you that
America is systemically racist they are
lying all evidence points to contrary
every attempt to fix this non-existent
problem in the name of equity is making
the country worse Heather McDonald is
shutting down that malignant ideology of
anti-racism in her brand new book when
race trumps Merit how the pursuit of
equity sacrifices Excellence destroys
Beauty and threatens lives she exposes
how the BLM fueled Equity obsession is
destroying Western Civilization
we no longer enforce many criminal laws
because doing so has a quote disparate
impact on minority criminals by lowering
standards Heather explains we've
jeopardized scientific progress
destroyed public order and poisoned the
appreciation of art and culture when
race Trump's Merit is an eye-opening
book and Heather is unafraid to break
taboos about academic achievement and
crime she provides the data and the life
stories that show the damage being done
to the country in real time in the name
of equity the book is Fabulous As is
everything that Heather writes go check
it out today when race Trump's Merit is
available on Amazon and wherever
excellent books are sold
you want to talk about trade-offs
there's a Wisconsin High School which
girls after their practice after gym
class they'll take a shower
and in that
locker room you got 14 year old girls
trying to shower and then you got an 18
year old man who identifies as a woman
and the 18 year old man comes in
and in this
High School the girls often will shower
in their bathing suits but this 18 year
old man who identifies as a woman he
decided he's not going to identify or
he's not going to wear his bathing suit
rather he's going to strip down
completely naked and expose himself this
is an 18 year old dude to 14 year old
little girls this occurred just on March
3rd this was not that long ago
is that worth it it's your daughter 14
year old daughter she goes in she
showers after gym class or after a
sports practice in her High School 14
year old daughter looks and there's a
fully grown 18 year old dude stripped
naked right in front of her showing off
everything he's got
are you going to tolerate that is that
trade-off worth it
to maybe make the guy feel a little bit
better even though there's really no
evidence it's even making him feel
better in the long run
is that worth it
no
and this is why by the way
we can no longer tolerate this ideology
anywhere in society
at any level
this is why
it's not because we're meanies it's not
because we're forcing the issue we
didn't force the issue it's the libs who
forced the issue
there was one of the people from Media
Matters
Zachary Drennan or drenner he is one of
the pro-trans people over at Media
Matters and he asked me because he posts
my Clips all the time he's my
effectively my publicist over there
Media Matters and he he asked me one
time he said Michael
why have you taken such a hard line on
this issue back when you interviewed
Blair white some years ago Blair white
is a man who's kind of he's mostly right
wing but he identifies as a woman but he
knows that he's not really a woman and
it's you know he's got a kind of nuanced
view on the issue and he said when you
back when you interviewed Blair white
you asked the question what pronouns am
I supposed to use to refer to you
so why now are you taking such a hard
line well I haven't changed my view of
things
exactly I haven't changed my view of
what makes a man what makes a woman what
pronouns are supposed to be used for men
and women
but back in those days those long ago
days of five years ago
sometimes
people would make little exceptions or
little at least little jokes
because there have always been a very
small number of
people who indulge either a sexual
fetish or a kind of a or they've just
got some issues where they think they're
the Opposites actually very much want to
be one
and very often society would just kind
of let it slide a little bit
okay we'd say if you if you met a man
who was dressed up as a woman you might
say oh hello how are you doing Milady
and hi there Sheila yeah isn't she
really nice or whatever and you kind of
make an exception or you would make a
little joke about it maybe or
in the case of the bathrooms
for a very long time there have been
every one in a million some guy who
dresses up as a woman and goes into the
bathroom and if you ever saw it happen
you'd think this is pretty weird and
maybe you'd be a little bit more on
guard and if a guy saw it you know you'd
keep keep a little situational awareness
here but people would just kind of let
it slide out of pity
for these very very troubled individuals
and for the fact of this Fallen World in
which things don't always make sense and
things go awry
often
the libs will no longer allow us to
express that kind of pity or make those
kinds of exceptions because the libs are
now trying to enshrine this
eccentricity this absurdity they're
trying to enshrine it as a principle of
our society they're trying to establish
it as a principle of law they're trying
to make us all say this is the truth
this is true and if a man says he's a
woman he has the right to walk into any
women's bathroom he wants he has the
right to shower in front of any 14 year
old girls he wants and we can't tolerate
that you're you're forcing the issue and
you're making us say no it's a lie
you're totally wrong you have no right
to do this at all
I can't even if you're gonna call
societies hold attention to it we can't
allow this it's just wrong all right
you're you are forcing the issue
and the libs have forced that issue they
started to force this issue after they
got the redefinition of marriage all of
these pro-lgbt organizations that wanted
to keep the money rolling in and wanted
to keep the activism going and wanted to
push the ideology further they all
pivoted to transgenderism the quote
unquote Human Rights Campaign especially
which that was the the group that had
the equal signed bumper sticker
they realized well we're a big powerful
Lobby and we got everything that we
wanted so what do we do now we got to
keep the money coming in all right we'll
become the trans organization now and so
they started pushing for it
and they forced us to take a clear
stance on it so that's it do you want 18
year olds stripping naked in front of
your 14 year old daughter in showering
with her no then transgenderism has to
be eradicated from public life entirely
for the good of society especially for
the good of the confused people who have
fallen prey to that the whole
Preposterous ideology at every level
period and that's why you're seeing
Republican politicians now adopt that
stance when I said it at CPAC a month
ago a little over a month ago now the
libs totally freaked out they lied about
what I said including the White House
now you're seeing Ron DeSantis down in
Florida adopted that position just last
week great good stuff good on him you're
seeing a lot of other Republicans around
the country adopt that position
we have to adopt that position we have
no other choice that's that's that's
what happens when the libs Force an
issue speaking of the public turning on
this issue Bud Light has just placed
that VP of marketing who pushed for the
Dylan Mulvaney beer can just placed her
on leave
this is Alyssa heinershide
not to be confused with sweet little
Elisa there's a huge variety among
leases around here
Alyssa heinershide
VP of marketing at Bud Light will for
now be replaced by Budweiser Global
Marketing VP Todd Allen
according to Anheuser-Busch inbev
telling ad age but she's just on leave
she hasn't been fired she's just she's
laying low for a little bit even this is
indecisive
which reminds me of an old political
principle which is sometimes a wrong
decision can be better than indecision
here since the Dylan Mulvaney
controversy Budweiser doubled down on
the sponsorship then pretended it didn't
know anything about the sponsorship then
made an advertisement about horses or
something then issued an apology letter
where there was no apology and it was
just the Budweiser CEO talking about how
much he supports the military or
something and then they but then they
can sort of continue to double down and
anyway now they're putting the VP on
leave but I don't know it's not it's
very very
indecisive and it's it's harming them
immensely I think they could have
survived it if they would just shut up
but they can't do it so they lose six
and a half billion in market cap and now
lots of bars won't even carry their beer
and now you've got Kid Rock just
shooting machine guns and boxes of Bud
Light because of how outrageous this
ideology is and now it's going to be
hard for them to recover
had they been decisive they either could
have doubled down and said yep we're now
the pro trans beer and plenty of
companies have done that and survived or
they could have said nope this is insane
we support Frat Boys and construction
workers which is the actual
customer base of Bud Light but that
indecision has has given them the worst
of Both Worlds speaking of the public
turning public opinion
and speaking of Governor DeSantis great
news out of Florida 41 of Floridians
support Ron desantis's new six-week
abortion ban now they're going to be
some people who say six week abortion
man what about the baby zero to six
weeks I know I agree abortion is wrong
it's wrong to murder people
especially wrong to murder innocent
little babies and so yeah it's wrong and
we should just get rid of abortion
totally there are plenty of other
alternatives to abortion abortion solves
no problems it does not Rectify any
crimes it's just a crime in and of
itself totally agree
but you see DeSantis now just starting
to ratchet it up a little bit okay we
got this band we got a 15-week ban now
we're going to go to a six-week ban the
great news here
is that the public seems to be going
along with him
at no point as Charlie cookbook points
out at National Review at no point in
the history of Gallup polling
did Gallup find 41 support for a ban on
abortion before
12 weeks in fact
support for abortion used to be much
much higher he says if we average out
the responses that Gallup obtains
between July 1996 and may 2022 we see
that 64 percent of Americans believe
that abortion should generally be legal
in the first three months of pregnancy
and now you've got 41 saying
it shouldn't be legal after six weeks so
the this is one of these few issues on
which the public has become
much more pro-life well it's obviously
this is the one issue in which it's
become more pro-life this is one of the
few issues in which the public has moved
much much more into our corner and
you're seeing that play out in real time
and you're seeing the evidence of that
because conservative legislators and
governors are pushing these kinds of
bills reminds me of a line from Cardinal
Manning which is that there is a day to
come that will reverse The Confident
judgments of men we live in this ever
ever present or we think that we live in
an ever-present where nothing is ever
going to change the way things are right
now that's how they're always going to
be that's not true that's not how time
works that's not how history works
progressives think history works
in this totally straight fashion from
Bad olden days to good future days where
they're going to get rid of all the
conservatives and they're going to live
in a Utopia that's also not how history
works
sometimes The Confident judgments of men
will be reversed sometimes
the advancement of History sees people
moving more and more over to our views
these sane views of things it's a
reminder too of a line that's that's
alternately credited to Dean Inge and
Fulton Sheen which is that if you wed
yourself to the spirit of the age you
will find yourself a widow in the next
to lessen to all those squishy
Republicans don't
just buy into whatever you think is
popular or fashionable or inevitable
don't do it
buy into what is right this is what
DeSantis said on the trans issue he said
look
he said basically exactly what I just
said he said if you
are going to force this issue on us
you're telling me I've got to live
according to lies you're telling me that
I've got to participate in a lie I'm not
going to do that if you pursue the truth
it might make you unpopular at any
particular moment but you're going to be
in a much better position in the long
run my favorite comment yesterday is
from have a seat over there who says
I want a Will Smith docu-series starring
Michael Knowles as Will Smith I think
that's a great idea I think it it'll
It's a Wonderful palette cleanser after
you watch the new Netflix Cleopatra
it's it's gonna it's gonna be great
we're gonna we're gonna have color blind
casting okay good I will get to the Will
Smith movie right after I finish my
Malcolm X biopic
it's gonna be really really great I'll
already start practicing keep my wife's
name out of your well this is a family
show I'll save the profanity for when we
make the movie
so we got some big
big news baby
we got some we got a new candidate in
the race
for president that candidate
Larry Elder my announcement Tucker
is that I'm announcing that I'm running
for the presidency of the United States
on your program and thank you so much
for giving me this honor and this
platform my website is
elderforpresident.com
and Tucker the reason I'm doing this is
because you know my father was a World
War II vet he served in in on the island
of Guam he was a Marine
first Black Marines are called Montford
Point Marines my older brother my late
older brother Kirk was in the Navy
during the Vietnam era and my little
brother Dennis actually served in
Vietnam in the Army I'm the only one who
didn't serve and I don't feel good about
that I feel I have a moral a religious
and a patriotic duty to give back to a
country that's been so good to my family
and to me and that is why I'm doing this
Tucker
well it's that's amazing congratulations
now uh Larry has been signaling that
he's interested in running for president
in in recent months so now he's coming
out he's doing it he is entering the
field his explanation is a fairly
standard conservative explanation which
is I want to serve you know if my my
country calls on me I'm going to do it
and Larry Elder is a very popular guy on
the right
so the the reason that Larry's
announcement to me is so interesting
is because Larry
is something of an anomaly in the
Republican field right now there has
always been something of an anomaly it's
La guy Sage from South Central who's
quite right wing uh
but he's something of an anomaly here in
that
the field is winnowing okay the field
which initially we were told no one's
going to run for president
Trump enters he's going to clear the
field
then Trump enters and
not everyone cleared the field some
people started announcing so then
conventional wisdom said
everybody's going to run for president
and that was briefly true everybody was
talking about running for president
everybody was exploring running for
president
and then
Ted Cruz said he wasn't going to run
and that at least he's signaled he's not
running I I don't know that he's
explicitly come out and said I am not
running for president but he he does not
appear to be doing the things that a
candidate would be doing I'm not even
playing Kauai since we uh together for
three years
um it just doesn't seem like he's
running in 2024. Mike Pompeo came out
and explicitly said I'm not running in
2024 even though he had been strongly
signaling that he would Mike Pence it
remains a little bit uncertain
who else
a lot of the big guys seem to be sitting
this one out
because the field looks right now like a
two-man race you've got Vivek then
enters Nikki Haley enters Tim Scott
enters
maybe you get another candidate Chris
Christie is making some signals that
he'll run Chris sununu is making some
signals that he'll run ASA Hutchinson I
guess is declared that he's running
people haven't talked about that very
much Joe Exotic of course from Tiger
King but in terms of the relay
top polling top tier candidates
seems like it might be a more modest
field
than a lot of people say and Larry Elder
might have a spot on that debate stage
now speaking of Tucker Larry made that
comment on Tucker Carlson
Tucker's gotten in a lot of trouble
because he has reminded people about Ray
apps and we've done that on this show
and conservatives at
at least the real conservative Outlets
have kept bringing up this guy Ray apps
you remember rayaps was he was the one
person caught on camera
encouraging an Insurrection on January
6th and we're gonna storm the capital
we're gonna go in and actually the night
before January 6th I think by my
calculation that would be January 5th
ray-ups was saying we're going to go in
we're going to storm the capital we're
gonna get him and then all the people
around him all the pro-trump
demonstrators they said fed fed fed this
guy's trying to instigate something
don't don't listen to him so we called
that out and then there was something
else that was a little strange
all of these January sixth people right
down to the little grannies who were
just going into the capital rotunda all
these guys have been rounded up they've
had the book thrown at them some of them
have been placed in solitary confinement
and yet Ray apps
totally is let off the hook initially
his photo was up there go get reyeps on
the law enforcement websites and then
just kind of disappeared doesn't look
like he was ever arrested he's faced no
punishments well now 60 Minutes is doing
a fawning profile of him uh lamenting
how people on the right including an
especially Tucker Carlson
keep saying his name
he's obsessed with me he's
going to any means possible to destroy
my life and our Lives why
to shift blame on somebody else if you
look at it Fox News
Marjorie Taylor green
Ted Cruz Gates they're all telling us
before this thing that it was stolen
so you tell me
who has more impact on people than or me
apps once a loyal Fox News Watcher told
us he doesn't understand how he got cast
as the villain the Epps version is more
mundane they believe the 2020 election
had been stolen from Donald Trump and
considered January 6 a legitimate
protest it was a sloppy election and
then to top that off you have Talking
Heads reporting that there's problems
with the voting machines and different
things like that the election stolen so
yeah we had concerns I I wanted to be
there I wanted to witness this with my
own eyes
okay so this is a case of mistaken
identity you guys just know I'm not I'm
not a fed I'm not I'm just a guy who
sincerely believed this was a sloppy
election and so I just went there and I
encouraged people to go storm the
capital and I was accused of being a Fed
at the time but I kept up my charge I
said no no we got to go storm the
capital and then I'm the only prominent
January 6th there who's completely lit
off the hook
and so this is awful I don't know why
all these conservatives are trying to
ruin my life okay look I don't know I
don't know
whether or not rayapps has a
relationship with the federal government
I do know that this FBI and this doj
have used pretty nefarious means of
trying to undermine Donald Trump and
conservatives I know that this FBI and
boj send spies in to go infiltrate
Catholic churches because some of those
Conservative Catholics they're enemies
of the regime according to Joe Biden so
they're going to go in they're going to
try to flip the priests to rad on the
The Shepherd's flocks can you imagine I
know that I know that the FBI and the
doj were spying on Trump's campaign in
2016 on completely bogus grounds I know
that they did their very best
to undermine the duly elected
presidential Administration I know that
they do that all the time
so I just my only question is
let's say that rayapps is being
completely sincere here he's totally
telling the truth
why is Ray Epps the only prominent guy
from January 6th
not to have been arrested
why is Ray Epps the only guy as far as I
can tell caught on camera encouraging
people to breach the capital
why is he the more prominent in this
regard than the horn hat guy
who got the book thrown at him more
prominent than the Nancy Pelosi Lecter
and smiley Florida guy who got the book
thrown out and went to jail why is Ray
Epps the most prominent January 6th
there the most vociferous the most
aggressive
in his rhetoric
why is he the only one who just got
completely let off the hook and then
furthermore
why are the liberal media
producing fawning profiles of him
why does he get this fawning 60-minute
special why does he get fawning coverage
in the New York Times
little bit sus to me
speaking of the board
speaking of the Matrix we're all living
in
AI will soon be teaching reading and
writing at within 18 months according to
Bill Gates
so Bill Gates who's one of the more
prominent voices pushing the
liberal dystopia that we all seem to be
hurtling toward pushing the great reset
as some people call it Bill Gates
predicted that AI will play an integral
role in the education system within 18
months and he's probably right
Bill Gates says what a good teacher does
is take your essay and Mark it up and
say oh this isn't clear the summary
should have included this this is a high
cognitive exercise and software except
at the really trivial kind of grammar
level has had essentially zero
ability to do this particularly once you
get out of a very templated writing
exercise the amount of feedback to help
me improve my writing is very low but
these AIS are actually good at that and
and he's right about that
AI is a lot better than spell check and
Microsoft Word back in the 90s and
probably could teach you the nuts and
bolts of writing better than a lot of
people but what what this misses what
this very Pro AI movement misses
is that teaching is an act of love
pedagogy is an act of love
you you know this even if you didn't
like some of your teachers probably you
did like some of your teachers I stay in
touch to this day with some of my
teachers I correspond with my
kindergarten teacher to this day okay I
love my teachers
and what they taught me was a lot more
than the nuts and bolts of writing my
11th grade English teacher taught me how
to write everything I ever learned about
how to write I learned in 11th grade
English class
but I learned many many other things
from my teachers because pedagogy the
act of passing along knowledge is an act
of love that is
human and constitutes our culture
and if that is replaced by robots
then our culture is going to be an
increasingly robotic
decreasingly human culture it's music
Monday baby we got to get to it the rest
of the show continues now you don't want
to miss it become a member and use code
Knowles at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans dailywire.com
Knowles code nulls
[Music]